legendary activist investor Carl aikon
who made his career by exposing
corporate mismanagements before a US
short seller gave him a taste of his own
medicine Ian has lost about $15 billion
since us short seller Hindenburg accused
his company of manipulating stocks and
misleading shareholders the US
government has arrested go wangui a
self-exiled Chinese billionaire for
cheating his online followers of over $1
billion since 2018 he's being charged
with 11 counts in including Securities
fraud wire fraud and concealment of
money laundering founder of Nicola
Motors facing years in prison following
his conviction on fraud charges he
promised to revolutionize the Auto
industry but was found guilty of
misleading investors this is Sergey
prota until recently he lived
comfortably in France with an estimated
wealth of more than $400 million he's
basically the textbook example of an
oligarch on Tuesday he was found dead in
a rented Villa in Spain
on the outside it lookss like
billionaires have everything the money
the power the influence the private jet
the pen houses they get to play by their
own rules but in reality every single
billionaire out there is completely
miserable like they're actually sick in
their head but why well for starters it
has a lot to do with how they made their
money see anyone can make a few million
dollars or even tens of millions of
dollars but a billion no one gets to a
billion without doing some very sketchy
things see there are only really three
ways you can become a billionaire the
first option is a simplest you got a
trick I mean sell investors on your
vision so there are three main camps of
billionaires in terms of how they
actually made the money the first Camp
are people who really made their money
from investors uh whether it's private
investors or stock market investors at
the end of the day their actual money
that ended up in their pocket came from
investors and not from profits generated
directly from customers and often times
they might have companies that are
barely even profitable at all but they
do a really good job at getting money
from investors this is arv Ali by the
way he's the former president of Jordan
Belford's companies yes the real Wolf of
Wall Street and he's the adviser of that
celebrities pro athletes politicians and
the ultra Rich go-to when they want to
grow their net worth so he's been very
up close and personal with a ton of
billionaires so he knows firsthand what
it's actually like behind closed doors
why is getting people to invest the
simplest way to billions it's because
instead of having to convince someone to
buy your products to spend money on you
you're telling them to invest you're
telling them that they're actually going
to make money with this route you don't
ever actually have to build anything
with any seriousness because think about
it if you sell a product and that
product isn't good or doesn't work
you're going to get returns you're going
to get sued hung from The Gallows but if
you pump up some investment and it
crashes I mean that's just how the
market goes at least I'm in the arena
trying stuff some will work some don't
and yeah you will still walk away with
their cash but you need charm for this
route you got to get up every day get on
CNBC put on that fake smile to tell the
suckers what the next big thing is going
to be but what if you don't have the
Charisma to get billions of dollars and
invest their money well then you go to
option number two you take advantage of
cheap Free Labor the second Camp are
people who do a really good job at
exploiting cheaper Free Labor so
nowadays they tend to do it by
exploiting you know very close to Free
Labor in other countries and and
capturing that Arbitrage between you
know how much they charge you as an end
consumer and how much it costs them
essentially and uh that tends to be and
and The Wider that Gap is between how
much they can charge you and how much it
cost them that's where they can really
make a lot of money and so you often see
this with luxury goods um and diamonds
or any of these sort of categories of
products those are where the the
founders of the companies uh tend to
make a lot of money uh where they really
exploit extremely cheap labor or free
labor and they charge the end consumer a
significant amount uh regardless of the
product wealth at the end of the day
mainly comes from labor someone had to
put the hours into doing the thing to
create the thing heck even when you
invest in stocks you make money off of
the people in that company doing the
labor for you which is why if you can
get the cost of Labor to zero or near
zero you will unlock the infinite money
hack why do you think dictators like
communism but at the end of the day this
R still requires you to compete in the
free markets even if you have the
advantage of Free Labor which brings us
to option number three to become a
billionaire get in bed with the
governments the third Camp are people
who are aligned to corrupt governments
and so you often see this in in many
third world countries but you even see
this with with people in China and
Russia but generally speaking if you are
aligned to certain types of governments
you can find ways especially if you have
an oil company you can find ways to
financially benefit quite a bit and it
is a risky situation to get yourself
into and those are the people that tend
to end up in jail or Worse yeah so often
times it's very much a family related
thing too where you know their parents
or grandparents are connected to the
government leaders but yeah at the end
of the day they end up having some sort
of private Corporation whether it's
construction oil companies things where
the government essentially gives
government contracts to those private
entities um that's where you're able to
benefit quite a bit from government
corruption because you're directly
getting money from the government but to
the public it looks normal like oh you
know of course we have to you know pay
this oil company or we have to pay this
construction company but uh who really
benefits it's usually one main guy that
uh gets the majority of that money
coming from taxpayer dollars but um
those are kind of the three main ways
that people end up becoming a
billionaire I haven't really seen an
exception to those three ways of making
that much money so think about this for
a second every billionaire either have
to commit fraud use slave labor or
they're embed with a corrupt government
that can kill them or imprison them at
any time along with a ton of other
unethical or illegal stuff they had to
commit every single one of them and now
they're at the top of the world where
everyone trying to tear them down do you
think you would sleep at night in their
position do you think you'll ever be
able to stop looking over your shoulder
do you think you would ever have any
semblance of Peace think of it as a if
you robbed a bank even if you got away
with the crime you would spend the rest
of your life as a fugitive you will
spend the rest of your life knowing that
you're hunted that at any moment you
could just lose everything get arrested
and it would have all been for nothing
so you can never truly enjoy your
success or feel comfortable with your
money this is actually the perfect
analogy for billionaires but that is
just the first reason why billionaires
have a horrible quality of life and in
this video me and Arvid are going to
expose it all I don't think you know if
everybody got a chance to to live their
life for a single day I think everybody
would realize this is the sort of the
worst experience of Life anyone can
practically have and I know what you're
thinking who cares Jake they're rich we
shouldn't have sympathy for them and
you're right we shouldn't but we should
learn from their misery stay dangerous
subscribe for more and let's get into
[Music]
it the one thing that all these
billionaires have in common is that they
all use financial advisors but why
they're super rich and obviously Highly
Educated aren't they smart enough to
manage their own money well yeah but
rich people know that when it comes to
preserving and growing your wealth it's
less about how smart you are and it's
more about not making stupid emotional
decisions that blow all of your money
think about it all the answers to
investing are out there already people
have figured it out you just need
someone that is certified in the stuff
to guide you so you can focus on what
you do best that is why you need
advisors the problem is finding a
professional adviser is tricky a lot of
them act like they have your best
interest at heart when really they don't
but luckily that is where money pickle
comes in today's paid sponsor with money
pickle you can book a free video call
with one of their certified planners or
fiduciaries just explain your situation
to them in a few words and money pickle
will match you with the trusted adviser
for you on your video call they'll be
able to really understand your situation
and give you teror made advice specific
to you and only you you can ask them
about investing taxes IRAs 401ks and any
other Financial concerns you have as a
US resident think of it as getting to
talk to your own personal AI but you
know it's a real person that is actually
certified in this stuff there are a ton
of times to choose from so you're not
going to have trouble finding one that
works for your time zone and your
schedule so click the link below and
schedule your free call now click the
link below and book your call
[Music]
now to imagine what it's like being a
billionaire think about how it would
feel if you genuinely believe that at
any moment your life could be over so
the first thing is that for every pretty
much every billionaire around the world
every single day they genuinely feel
like they're about to go bankrupt or
they're going to go to jail in countries
like China and Russia they very commonly
do end up in jail and so it's not like a
sort of a paranoid situation it's more
than anything else is kind of the likely
outcome for them and in countries like
the US and throughout Western Europe the
bigger concern that they tend to have is
whether they're going to have so many
lawsuits that kind of buries them or
more often the companies that they
created usually it's one main company
that allow them to be so wealthy often
times declines either because of
markting conditions or because the
government cracks down on the company in
their paranoa is valid it's actually
very easy to go broke as a billionaire
even if you look at most S&P 500
companies they don't actually last more
than 20 years so if your entire
lifestyle is centered around this wealth
that you accumulated because of one main
company or even two main companies um
very likely that that wealth is going to
disappear and we also see this
historically if you take a look at the
majority of the wealthiest individuals
through all of human history they end up
losing all their wealth by the time it
passes down even to their grandkids it's
very very difficult to actually maintain
your wealth and they're very aware of
this so on a daily basis their actual
thought is how am I going to uh be okay
and it happens a lot more than you think
take Carl icon for example Carl icon was
a legendary investor worth billions of
dollars but all it took was one little
expose from a short seller called
Hindenberg research accusing Carl of
operating a pony-like scheme and boom he
lost $10 billion of his net worth in
less than a day today he's worth just $5
billion a staggering downfall from his
$25 billion net worth Just 4 months ago
now you may be saying but Jake he's
still worth $5 billion I would be happy
if I still have $5 billion after I had
$25 billion and you would think that but
trust me when I say losing money hurts a
lot more than knowing that you still
have a lot of money left whether we're
talking about losing your job but you
still have savings or losing $20 billion
but you still have 5 billion most of us
think that only regular people
experience that worry about money but
that fear never goes away no matter how
much money you make generally speaking
you know most of us no matter how much
money we have we tend to feel concerned
about our cash flow we you know we have
our income we have our expenses and
we're hoping that nothing really ruins
our income so that it doesn't
dramatically affect our lifestyle in
fact it's actually way worse for
billionaires when you're a billionaire
it's actually a much bigger problem
because for most people if they have a
job they would just get another job but
for a billionaire like how are you going
to be able to start from zero again you
know sort of recreate the lifestyle that
you have even the richest of the rich
don't ever truly feel financially secure
you and I probably feel way more
comfortable about our finances right now
than the average billionaire ever will
that's because on top of all these
reasons the only people that ever become
billionaires in the first place are
naturally the ones that are literally
mentally ill the biggest difference
between a billionaire and everybody else
is that they're a lot more mentally ill
than than the average
person
[Music]
think about how actually psycle you have
to be in order to never be satisfied
with anything that you actually make it
to billionaire status most of us will
stop if we got to a few million some of
us might only stop if we got to a few
hundred million but a billion that takes
a very specific kind of person they
genuinely are stuck in a mental state
feeling like they're dying poor and
that's what drives them to be able to
make make this much money it's never the
case that I built a company because they
enjoyed it and they worked hard all this
is sort of a false narrative they're
very obsessed with money uh every single
famous billionaire you can think of I'm
either connected to them directly or I'm
one degree away from them more often and
overall that I haven't seen like a
single exception to this they're all
extremely concerned about their
day-to-day if you felt that poor every
single day you would keep trying to make
more and more money until ideally you
don't feel so dying poor but they don't
ever have that physical feeling of
feeling okay like most people will end
up having if they reach a certain income
level the fact of the matter is everyone
on this planet doesn't feel like they
have enough many of us don't and we're
not saying to lower your expectations or
something just don't take it to a
psychotic extreme like these
billionaires to where it takes away all
your happiness everyone watching this
right now is technically wealthier than
almost every human being that's ever
walked the Earth including all the kings
and and queens of the past because you
have access to clean water you have a
wide variety of food that you don't have
to typically you know go out and Hunt
and Gather or even Farm most of the time
and you have access to electricity you
have access to the internet you know all
these luxuries that you have the a car a
plane like there there's just so many
luxuries that you have that most of
humanity have never experienced
especially even the kings and queens and
and even then even though you're
objectively way wealthier than anyone
you can think of throughout history most
of us can't go about our day just
feeling like we're rich I've never met
one person even the people who are worth
you know a lot more than than these sort
of public billionaires I've never met
one person who feels like they're find
finally okay most of the time people
will feel financially excited when their
income or net worth is going up but it's
a very temporary feeling as soon as you
know it stops going up you go back to
your Baseline of feeling worried about
your finances and especially if it
starts to go down you get even more
worried outside of let's say those those
few weeks or months or sometimes a year
where it starts to go up dramatically uh
usually you feel uh concerned when it
comes to your finances no matter who you
are really and I promise you not only do
they not feel wealthy but if anything
what drove them to make that much wealth
is that they have a mental illness that
you don't have and if you get that much
money you'll have a different form of a
problem but the main distinction is the
type of person you have to become to
make that kind of money most people
aren't willing to become that kind of
person and I've seen it over and over
again I've never really seen an
exception no matter you know who you
think of as a billionaire that has a
nice lifestyle privately they're all far
worse than any homeless person in Los
Angeles that I've seen in terms of their
level of mental illness to be honest and
I know what you're thinking but Jake if
I had a billion dollars I would be
perfectly happy I want to fall into the
same trap I mean you can think that I
mean there's plenty of proof with
everyone who's won the lottery that's
like the only really sort of scientific
evidence that if you get a large sum of
money you're going to end up if anything
in debt very quickly and you're going to
be depressed you're going to be in a lot
of legal issues you're life's going to
get pretty messy very quickly and
there's there's some few exceptions to
it where if you look at the
documentaries there's some people who
like sort of stay secret about the fact
that they have the money and they never
actually touch it and they keep the same
lifestyle but outside of those rare
exceptions if you just look at as a
science experiment people who are middle
inome and they suddenly get injected
with a lot of money what quickly happens
is pretty much what happens to any
wealthy individual which is that your
expenses rise with it to a point where
it becomes unsustainable and then you
can't bring in new income anymore and
now you're in a huge situation because
you went from let's say making 100 Grand
a year to now being 50 million in debt
like what do you do so so it's like it's
a very tricky situation and I I
acknowledge you know what what anybody
would think which is like you know this
this is not right for us to be
empathetic or whatever towards them I'm
not empathetic towards them at all
really I'm just saying that you
objectively are among the wealthiest you
know
0.001% of humans that have ever lived
and you still don't feel wealthy and I
promise you not only do they not feel
wealthy but if anything what drove them
to make that much wealth is that they
have a mental illness that you don't
have and if you get that much money
you'll have a different form of a
problem billionaires are so miserable
that arfid won't even work with them
anymore because it's just that miserable
being around them so is there a reason
why you s working with billionaires yeah
I mean there it's exactly what I said
you know in this whole interview it's
like they're by far the most miserable
people to deal with and they're
extremely cheap way cheaper than anyone
you could really practically think of
and I would say dealing with them in
their environment it takes a toll on you
emotionally and mentally so generally
speaking I I prefer finding individuals
anywhere in the world where I align to
them you know my message gets across to
them like the way that I speak what I
say it's not meant for most people it's
meant for a small percentage of people
who really resonate with it I prefer
this life of trying to help as many
people as I can across the world
regardless of their background or
situation and so that's my main focus
right now and here's the thing pretty
much every material thing you could ever
want you don't need to be a billionaire
to afford
[Music]
them
let's play a game it's called attempt to
spend all of bill gates' money go ahead
and try as hard as you can to spend his
billions buy 500 Ferraris 1,000 drones
20,000 horses 100,000 acres of farmland
and guess what that won't even make a d
you haven't even spent a single billion
dollars let alone come close to wiping
out Bill gates' Fortune of $116 billion
even if you tried to make the most
absolutely ridiculous purchases it's
basically impossible to spend all that
money much or less enjoy those purchases
and even if you could spend all that
money you were only one single person
the difference between you enjoying 100
cars versus 1,000 cars is probably not
that big at some point very early on you
start to get diminishing returns on what
you can buy and enjoy it's pretty easy
to run out of stuff to buy if you get to
like a million dollars a year um you can
pretty much have the perfect lifestyle
if you know how to spend it you could
have as ideal of a lifestyle as you
could ever dream of in terms of having
someone clean your house house having
you know your meals made for you all
this stuff like it's not actually that
expensive you kind of run out at a
certain point like what are you going to
do just store Mac's in your house a
store Nordstrom in your house like there
isn't like what else is there to do
really and even with the exotic cars
like they just sit there and you look at
them you know but like what are you
going to do with it and even if you live
in super wealthy communities like it's
just a suburb like there isn't that much
to do there isn't anything that
glamorous I would say that they have
access to that most people don't have
access to the only big difference is the
fact that all of us have an imagination
that they're just sitting there like a
king you know laughing at the rest of us
or something like that no matter who you
are as a person at the end of the day
there's nothing more you can do with
your day besides waking up eating some
food you know walking around sitting
down thinking about things watching
things except if you have the billions
now you have much bigger problems to
worry about at the same time so if a few
million dollars is all you need to get
most of life's luxuries without all the
giant problems of being a billionaire
and if luxuries are your only goal like
you don't care about making an impact or
whatever then it would be logical to
stop once you have the millions another
thing about being a billionaire is that
you don't actually have a billion
dollars sitting in your bank account to
use at any time NOP most of all of your
fortune is usually going to be tied up
in things like stocks or Equity I don't
think you know for the most part most
Bill billionaires don't actually have
maybe more
than you know maybe 20 or 50 million
dollars that they can ex you know spend
each year comfortably sometimes
generally speaking I think you know
anybody who um uh is listed on on the
billionaires list they they don't really
have a billion dollars of easily liquid
assets um available all those massive
home and luxury purchases that
billionaires are making even they are
taking out loans just like the rest of
us sometimes they'll they'll make a
lavish purchase or something but usually
that's on on a loan even those massive
man mansions that you hear about and
those Yachts they'll always take a loan
against it they they don't just put up
cash they might initially put up cash
but they'll always take a loan against
it being a billionaire might seem like a
superpower from the outside but it's
really just an elaborate illusion they
want to present themselves as extremely
rich that's the whole point like if you
see that an investor is worth $50
billion then you're going to think he's
the best investor in the world so you're
going to want to give your money to him
that's that's kind of the heart of the
situation so after hearing about all
these sketchy billionaires you might get
this curve Ed I want to be rich but I
don't want to screw people over but is
it even possible to get rich while being
ethical well it actually is and by the
way don't forget to click the link below
for your free video call with one of
money pickle certified financial
planners or fiduciaries so you can get
personalized advice on your finances
taxes Investments IRAs 401ks and much
more click the link below to book a call
[Music]
now
so is there from all your experience is
there an ethical and honest way to make
a lot of money yeah so the best thing
that I've always seen and these are
actually the people who do genuinely
make millions of dollars for many many
years to come is simply a situation
where you take your existing job or
profession and you turn it into a
business let's say you're a a plumber or
you molans or you tutor people it
doesn't matter what you really do in the
case of tutoring the nice thing is that
you know you can start by tutoring a
small number of individuals in a subject
that uh you feel comfortable in uh and
then over time you can learn other
subjects that you can tutor more
individuals in and then over time again
you can expand you know the level of
subject that you're that you're teaching
even to college entrance exams and I go
through this in in this sort of free
manual that I wrote where in that
tutoring example like how someone can go
from making let's say $40,000 a year
into making a million dollar but it's
not really about making a million
dollars it's simply about finding a way
to add more value to more people versus
a situation like Kathy Wood where she
just tricked a lot of people all at once
and it you know plummeted down as
expected and now you know she's in an
interesting situation but I always
recommend just turning your job or
profession into a business by simply
finding a way to service more
individuals or even more companies the
last thing I'll say on this is like
imagine you're employed by a company and
you provide some sort of services
imagine it's marketing services or
Engineering Services now can you see
that employer as a customer and now find
other companies that you can also
service and then eventually you can have
people help you service those companies
so if you want to make more money while
living a happy peaceful life unlike
these billionaires then focus on
actually providing value instead of
constantly trying to think of schemes of
how to screw over the masses are you
pretty confident that anyone with a
regular job like Plumbing or tutoring or
whatever can do this and make like at
least a million a year I'm not even
recommending making that much money it's
really just changing your mindset to
trying to add a lot of value to a lot
more people that's at the heart of it so
it depends on which you know City you
live in which country you're in and what
your starting point is in my case like I
came from the poorest country one of the
poorest countries in the world really
but uh across the board I've always
found that the people who make a lot of
money consistently longterm in an
ethical way they end up being people who
simply turn their professions into a
business by just finding a way to add
value to more people and that reflects
in how much money that you ultimately
make and one other aspect to that is
often times you might be missing a skill
that you need to be able to add more
value to more people and so that might
be step one for for a lot of people
watching this is if the profession that
you're in uh can't possibly turn into a
business for you then you can simply
learn you know a skill that you feel
excited about learning and then finding
a way to turn that profession into a
business and if people are resonating
with what you're talking about uh you
got a YouTube channel and and they can
book a call because of you yeah yeah
thanks for thanks Jake for encouraging
me if you guys want to you know I have a
I have a YouTube channel it's nothing
like that sophisticated it's just me
sharing my honest uh private insights
that I've had from dealing with all
these people all these years and just
getting the answers that I've been
looking for and sharing that as much as
I can with everyone publicly and more
importantly making that a way for people
to connect with me and and really have a
one-on-one call and that's that's the
thing that I really enjoy doing the most
Arvid recently put out a free 1-hour
training on his YouTube channel That
goes really deep into how to turn your
95 job into a super profitable business
I watched it I was super shocked at how
thoroughly he thought through every
single little aspect from how to get
clients to what to say to how to say it
it's actually one of the best business
trainings I've ever seen and it's free
so click the card on the screen to watch
now this is best for people who have a95
or if you're a solopreneur looking to
scale while working less Arvid has been
my business adviser for years and he's
the one who taught me how to scale this
channel can't recommend him enough and
if you're interested in talking to him
one-on-one afterwards you can book a
call with the link in the description of
that video